jetzt gucken wir gemeinsam auf unseren
Industriestandort wir sehen jetzt die
Schreckensmeldung von BASF der Kanzler
wird morgen da sein und wird erklären
warum so viele Arbeitsplätze dort
voraussichtlich verloren gehen werden
wen wird das noch treffen wovon gehen
sie aus große Unternehmen
wird uns alle treffen machen wir uns
doch nichts vor das ist doch nicht nur
ein Unternehmen macht dicht oder geht
weg und dann war's das jetzt für ein
paar 100 Mitarbeiter nein es trifft doch
die gesamte Gesellschaft wir heben da
hängen doch alle miteinander zusammen
wir sind vernetzt wir konsumieren wir
fahren in den Urlaub es können keine
Preise mehr kalkuliert werden es wird
die gesamte Wirtschaft treffen es wird
jeden von wiederhole noch mal wir haben
die höchsten Strompreise in der ganzen
Welt in G20 überall und mehr als die
Hälfte davon ich glaube 53 % sind
Steuern und Abgaben da muss man was tun
alle anderen wettbewerbsländer die
lachen sich ins Fäustchen die deutschen
Unternehmen gehen überall hin überall
ist es günstiger da muss die Regierung
was machen runter mit den Steuern wenn
sie jetzt im Moment ein Topmanager
werden Herr Marquardt bei einem
führenden Unternehmen beim großen
Stahlunternehmen großen
Automobilunternehmen und sie sehen im
Moment die Entwicklung der Energiepreise
könnten sie es überhaupt verantworten
gegenüber ihnen Mitarbeitern vor allen
Dingen aber gegenüber den Aktionären
hier weiter zu produzieren
ach die Aktionäre Hamster gut die
Aktionäre können überall investieren in
Amerika und wenn BASF nach China kommt
und geht dann habe ich eine BASF Aktie
dies genauso wird der Aktionär ist
überhaupt nicht das Problem sein
internationaler Anleger gott sei dank
der deutsche auch der kann in der ganzen
Welt anlegen
ja genau
mal ausklammern aus der Sorge aber die
Mitarbeiter ich fürchte aber wenn ich
ein Unternehmen habe so wie science muss
ich verantwortlich für meine Mitarbeiter
denken aber sie sind Top-Manager sie
sind für den Börsenkurs verantwortlich
erfahren heute sie kennen genau diese
Situation jetzt sehen sie die
Entwicklung der Energiepreise würden sie
das in dieser Situation verantworten und
zu sagen alle die nächsten 10 Jahre
immer weiter in Deutschland für eine
andere Antwort darauf geben sehen Sie
ich kann das verstehen dass 2,2
Milliarden mehr Kosten bei der BASF dass
der Bruder Müller sagt das kann ich
nicht weiter leisten ich kann nicht
miese machen dann dann sind wir dann ist
das Unternehmen in der substanzgefährdet
also muss ich abbauen hat er ja gesagt
ich will Kosten einsparen was der heißt
am Ende Arbeitsplätze was man aber schon
erwarten muss von unseren
industrieführern ist dass sie ihren Mund
vielleicht mal ein bisschen früher
aufmachen die deutsche Industrie hat
doch viel zu lange diesen Trubel in
Berlin zugeschaut das ist doch nicht
gestern erst passiert wer hat denn 2011
Frau Merkel gesagt lasse das mal lieber
Mittag mit dem Ausstieg wer hat den 2017
als der Kohleausstieg beschlossen worden
ist dass die ostdeutsche Braunkohle
zerstört wird wer hat denn da gesagt das
wollen wir eigentlich nicht sie haben
alle geschrieben ich nicht ich war immer
dabei habe gesagt das ist einfach
hängnisvoller Kurs und deswegen erwarte
ich das von unseren industrieführern die
haben Mitarbeiter in der Obhut in der
Verantwortung für deren Arbeitsplätze
das erwarte ich nicht unbedingt
Gewerkschaften genau der Gedanke sie
regieren mit und sie drücken im Grunde
dabei zu wie diese Unternehmen gerade
dicht machen wie Betriebe pleite gehen
in der fdp-rolle sage ich halt wir
leisten Widerstand aber ich gebe dem
fahren heute direkt nein ja auch das
materiellen teilweise den Grünen in den
Arsch kriechen entschuldigen sie ja ach
das ist doch grauenvoll was man dass sie
nicht ich denke mal voller schockierung
an den audi-Chef der heißt glaube ich
Dussmann
der vergangenen Woche in der Süddeutsche
Zeitung haben wir das Zitat vorliegen
vom Audi Chef der begeistert sich
nämlich als autobos plötzlich für
autofreie Sonntage und sagt genau das um
uns also in Deutschland besser
einzustimmen auf die Lage und die
Notwendigkeit des Sparens könnte es
wieder Sinn ergeben autofreie Tage zu
machen so wie in den 70er Jahren
kann auf den Autobahn das hat doch noch
dazu wenn sonntags frei kann der Rennrad
fahren auf der Autobahn das ist ein
Skandal der gehört ja von Audi abgelöst
beschädigt schädigend für Audi und
geschäftsschädigen für die ganze Familie
außerdem da kommt ja das Wort vor Auto
frei da könnte ich ja sagen darum frei
vor nichts da das ist Verbot das ist
Gängelung die Menschen kaufen sich ein
Auto von ihrem ersparten Geld um am
Samstag Sonntag zum Fußballverein zu
fahren oder die Wirtschaft oder Freunde
Verwandte besuchen da brauche ich keine
Maske im Auto in in der Eisenbahn und
ich kann und muss mich nicht nach
Fahrplänen richten das Auto ist ein
Symbol der Freiheit und da kommt ein
Vorstandsvorsitzender eines großen
audi-konzerns ja und sagt
autofeiertage können nur die Sonntage
sein also ich habe ja mit Leuten von
Audi gesprochen die wurden aber die
Verkäufer sind ja stocksauer die Grünen
freuen sich oder über den Satz vom Audi
Boss das kann man ich muss ehrlich sein
und sagen dass ich also das
ist eine Debatte die mich nicht
sonderlich interessiert ich glaube das
ist nicht viel hilft
Autofahrer interessiert das passiert
jedem der sonntags halt auch mal Auto
fährt ja die Kinder zum Fußball fährt
der Verwandte besucht am Wochenende der
mit der Familie unterwegs ist
um ehrlich zu sein glaube ich dass der
Audi Chef sich da auf andere Probleme
konzentrieren muss ich bin auch kein
großer Fan dieser Idee von Autos
sitzen da in ihrem Brüssel und im
Straßburg und sagen
ja das ist ja neben mir und wissen nicht
wie die deutschen Autofahrer denken und
fühlen die haben sich diese Symbol der
Freiheit gekauft die wollen nicht
geklingelt werden brauchen sie sonntags
sehr Autobahn natürlich Catering was
würde man bei ihnen in der Stadt im Ort
sagen wenn man ihnen sagt also ab heute
machen wir hier autofreien Sonntag schön
kann schwierig für Geschäft Leute ja das
ist eine Art von wohlstandsverwale also
die sich hier breit macht das muss man
schon sagen nicht denn man wenn so über
Probleme wir sind in einer der
schwersten energiekrisen und ein Manager
sagt auch lass mal den den den Gott
lieben Mann sein das das ist aber ein
ein Zeichen für unser Feuer also ich
würde sofort feuern und würde sagen das
erwarten auch die Kunden also ich glaube
dass ich nie wieder ein Audi kaufen
würde wenn solange der Mann da ist ja
ich war auf jeden Fall
brauchen sie viel ändern das heißt also
am Ende muss das schon eine eine
breitere Wirkung haben ich habe deswegen
etwas gemacht ich habe eine Initiative
in die Welt gerufen rettet die Industrie
aber gibt's Aufkleber die kann man sich
googeln rettet unsere Industrie rettet
unsere Industrie und wenn jeder das an
sein Auto klebt anstatt atomkraft nein
danke das war ja gestern nee das ist ja
längst sozusagen völlig altmodisch
rettet unsere
jeder würden Sie den Aufkleber tragen
wettet uns auch merken dass die Menschen
für ihre Industrie eintreten ich würde
den Aufkleber glaube ich neben den
atomkraft nein danke Aufkleber machen
aber ja dann schon widerspricht sich das
in diesen Zeiten
runterklappen bei mir nicht dran kleben
weil ich glaube das unterscheiden wir
uns eben das ist äh kann man auch nichts
mehr Atomkraft also überbrücken ich
finde das interessant weil das sozusagen
jetzt als grüne Idee gilt die Atomkraft
abzuschaffen aber beschlossen haben das
ja nicht die Grünen was allerdings
passiert ist ist dass wir die Zeit
verlinke das geschlossen haben
solo ja ich glaube nicht dass sie es
ganz alleine war ähm es gab damals
natürlich so überwältigende mehr
wahrscheinlich
zustimme ist dass wir 2011 gesagt haben
wir wollen aus der Atomkraft raus halte
ich für eine sehr richtige Entscheidung
aber mit der Entscheidung hängt
natürlich zusammen dass man dann die
nächsten Jahre auch intensiv daran
arbeiten muss wenn alles auf diesen
Ausstieg vorzubereiten das glaube ich in
den letzten elf Jahren einfach nicht
passiert
Frau Schimke und die Herren Markwort und
fahrenhold und helldörfer haben sich
aufgeregt über die Aussagen des Audi
Bosses die Wahrheit die offenbar
dahinter steckt ist ja dem ist es
relativ wurscht mittlerweile was der
deutsche Autofahrer was der deutsche
Markt macht der verdient sein Geld
sowieso schon längst vor anders na gut
das kann jeder von uns bewerten wie er
mag ich glaube wir werden von der
deutschen Wirtschaft keine Revolution zu
erwarten haben ne aber was wir was wir
was wir sehr wohl was wir sehr wohl
erwarten dürfen auch von unseren
Unternehmens Lenkern und Managern ist
dass sie die Interessen ihres
Unternehmens vertreten und die ihre
Mitarbeiter
sein Interesse kann ja nicht sagen wir
machen jetzt komplett autofreie Woche
und die deutschen brauchen keine Autos
funktionieren finde diese Aussage ist
ein Stück weit Ausdruck von von
lebensferne von realitätsferne von dem
schweben auf einer bestimmten Ebene von
dem Wunsch Akzeptanz und an Entscheidung
zu generieren bei den mächtigen bei der
Regierung aber es hat sehr sehr wenig zu
tun mit den Menschen für die diese Autos
gebaut werden aber stimmt das dass dem
Audi Boss und möglicherweise auch den
BMW-Chef von dem VW-Chef mittlerweile
der deutsche Kunde eigentlich wurscht
sein kann das spielt einfach keine Rolle
mehr naja ich würde sagen der Deutsche
im Allgemeinen den Eindruck kann man
bekommen wenn man draußen auf die Straße
geht sich mit den Menschen unterhält
sich mit dem Metzger vor Ort unterhält
dann ist das Stimmungsbild ein komplett
anderes als das was sie aus diesem
Chefetagen zu hören bekommen na gut
erhalten wir aber auch nicht nur mit dem
deutschen Markt die Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland die Industrie ist schon
darauf ausgerichtet auch Sachen zu
exportieren deswegen finde ich jetzt
unabhängig von dieser Aussage ich habe
ja gesagt ich mache mir den nicht so
eigen finde ich es auch wichtig dass man
natürlich den Blick für die Außenwelt
auch außerhalb von Deutschland nicht
verliert und dass man sich auch anschaut
wie können wir denn Produkte generieren
in welchem Bereich auch immer die
konkurrenzfähig bleibt die
konkurrenzfähig sind auch für das
ausländische Geschäft und da merke ich
wenn man sich jetzt hier aufregt gerne
über 2035 Verbrenner aus man muss sagen
da werden weiter noch Verbrenner fahren
aber
es ist so dass die meisten es ist so
dass die meisten Unternehmen ob es
Daimler Audi oder VW sind das jetzt
nicht als extreme Gängelung empfinden
sondern schon auch sagen dass es
eigentlich gut dass wir mal eine
Zielvorstellung haben und die werden sie
auch einhalten können ihre Verbrenner
halt woanders und auf dem chinesischen
verkauft das in dem kleinen deutschen
Markt hin und produzieren weiter
Verbrenner für Kinder aber ich glaube an
nicht nur an das sollte Dichter und
Denker sondern auch an das Volk der
Ingenieure und Techniker und ich bin
Technologie offen wer weiß was bis dahin
2035 noch entwickelt wird das Benzin
wird anders wird günstiger es gibt noch
so viele technische Innovationen in
diesem deutschen Volk die werden von der
Politik einfach weggewischen ich bin
misstrauisch wenn Politiker so wie ich
die so wenig von Ingenieurskunst
verstehen ein Datum festlegen 2035 also
ich hoffe dass es noch mal überholt wird